our founding fathers were booze hounds
so much so that Benjamin Franklin
published a dictionary of 228 words that
all describe one thing being blind drunk
in the 13 colonies we love to drink
colonial Americans were perpetually
bombed especially since water wasn't
always clean and accessible many of our
nation's most respected men could be
found with a glass or two in hand in
fact Thomas Jefferson drafted the
Declaration of Independence while drunk
on Madeira George Washington racked up
an epic bar tab of over 160 bottles for
just 54 delegates
zone me and John Adams went on a
seven-week binge drinking six hours a
night with younger congressmen keep
drinking so Franklin took a stab at his
peers and published the terms to go for
hurt at local pubs in the drinkers
dictionary here's what they said I've
got corns in my head oh go eat a pudding
bag Thomas you're one to talk Washington
you're as dizzy as a goose I'm shambled
my goodness Hamilton you've got a brass
eye today well the king was his cousin
clearly gentlemen you're all wasted
you